help me out so as you can see I shave my
head in the same way you've shaved your
head all these years right what's up
with the hair what are we doing here how
can I get the Akon
what do I got to go to you got to grow
it out just a little bit more because
you know I got I got this [ __ ] Eminem
hairline my my dad's bald as [ __ ] so I
don't go to the barber I just go to my
bathroom and I just shave my head twice
a week I haven't shaved in about a week
and a half but like uh you obviously
have hair right yeah it was so so oh no
I went to Turkey I went to Turkey and
got a procedure was it painful don't
forget in the beginning my whole front
was loose it was real thin was it
painful nah no no it's the painful part
is the beginning when they gotta numb
you up um that numbing ain't no joke
what they speak a needle like this big
non-stop like did they do the graph
thing where they take a piece so that's
what they did yeah they took the draft
because your [ __ ] looks good it looks
like it looks amazing yeah I love it
like Tory Lanez should have went to your
guy I told a [ __ ] I said Victoria to
the king of my man
yeah bro you gotta you know